geomagnetische super stürme wüten im
alcatraz knapp an der erde vorbei und
roboterhand setzt neue maßstäbe das sind
drei der fünf themen in den klicks um
top five news allgemein für zuhause
wolltet ihr auch schon mal den ironman
schub von tony stark haben von einer
super rüstung aller ironman träumt jetzt
auch der autohersteller hyundai zusammen
mit robotik experten entwickeln sie
derzeit nach dem vorbild von ironman ein
exoskelett dass es menschen ermöglichen
soll maschinelle kräfte nutzen zu können
zieht man sich dieses robotik skelett
über soll man über 60 kilogramm stemmen
können und zwar ohne körperliche
anstrengung eingesetzt werden sollten
diese super rüstung nicht nur im militär
oder in berufen bei denen die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
körperlich stark gefordert werden
sondern auch in medizinischen bereichen
menschen mit behinderung können damit
beispielsweise beim überwinden von
hindernissen geholfen werden die von
hyundai veröffentlichten bilder lassen
uns den stand der entwicklung nur
erahnen und die frage stellen wann ist
der erste anzug fertig und schweigt
allerdings über die zukunft des
projektes nasa patente freigegeben die
nasa hat über 1000 ihrer patente
freigegeben und damit nicht genug sie
haben auch alle auf ihrer website
zusammengestellt unter ihnen sind
patente zu schub dösen oder auch zur
raketen sicherheitssystemen die software
die 1969 bei der mondlandung in der
fähre eingesetzt wurde kann jetzt
übrigens auch ohne lizenzgebühren
eingesetzt werden
so wie ihr euch jetzt vermutlich die
frage nach dem warum stellt aber auch
ich mich gefragt warum und hier ist die
antwort zitat indem wir diese techniken
in die public domain entlassen fördern
wir eine neue ära des unternehmertums
die amerika wieder an die spitze der
hightech produktion und der
wirtschaftlichen konkurrenzfähigkeit
bringen wird so daniel lockt nähe von
der nasa mit 252 pda seine erde knapp
vorbei und wurde aufgezeichnet von 16
jahren also im jahr 2000 entdeckten
forscher den kometen 252 vielen jahren
dieses jahr im märz rauschte der kometen
in einer entfernt
von rund 54 millionen kilometern an
unserem planeten vorbei 54 millionen
kilometer klingt jetzt erst war nach
viel immerhin 14 mal die entfernung
zwischen mond und erde
aber das ist nicht viel 242 pda reiz
sich mit dieser distanz auf platz 5 der
kometen ein
die der erde besonders nah kam zitat
dank der kurze entfernung des kometen
hat habe zwar 52 pda mit einer auflösung
von 16 kilometern pro pixel aufzeichnen
können so yang yang li vom planetary
science institute in taxen bilder wie
diese vom hubble weltraumteleskop sind
eine rarität in der astronomie 252 pda
fliegt beispielsweise erst in fünf
jahren wieder an uns vorbei 2021 kommt
der komet jedoch nicht so nah an uns
heran den jetzt aufgezeichneten bildern
erhoffen sich die forscher so einiges in
der pressemitteilung des planetariums
instituts heißt es vonseiten yang ließ
dass sie mit diesen bildern kometen
eigenschaften klären wollte zu den
eigenschaften eines kometen gehört
beispielsweise die staub produktion nahe
der sonne und die rotation um die eigene
achse interessant ist die bauproduktion
deswegen da der komet im inneren eiskalt
ist und durch die wärme der sonne
angeregt wird sich von staub zu trennen
sensationelle roboter an diese
roboterhand setzt im bereich robotik
ganz neue maßstäbe forscher der
university of washington darunter e
motor auf wie kuba und sergej lieben die
bisher feinste und intelligentesten
roboterhand entwickelt obwohl die hand
erst ende des monats in stockholm auf
der international conference on robotics
and automation kurz ikra detailliert
vorgestellt werden soll können wir euch
heute schon im hintergrund ausschnitte
der hand und ihrer funktionsweise zeigen
kleiner spoiler für die leute die die
ecra verfolgen wollen die hand lernt aus
ihren fehlern
wir können uns also auf die messe
vorstellung freuen
geomagnetische super stürme wüten im all
die nasa hat geomagnetische stürme
gemessen und ausgewertet so genannte
magnetische re kollektionen setzen im
all gewaltige mengen energiereicher
elektronen frei die erde ist ja von
einem magnetfeld umgeben das durch
magnetfeldlinien dargestellt wird auch
bei der sonne gibt es diese
magnetfeldlinien und kommen sich
diese linien zu nah und mischen sich
dann connecten sie sich neu
dabei ändert sich die struktur eines
magnetfeldes erprobt und bei so einem
szenario werden dann elektronen auf
extrem hohe geschwindigkeiten
beschleunigt eine solche reaktion
konnten forscher nun im zuge der
magnetosphäre multi- scale mission
messen kurz mms und darstellen zitat es
war theoretisch vorhergesagt vor mms
aber noch nie beobachtet worden so
gamespot vom southwest research
institute welche energie konnte jetzt
gemessen werden den forschern zufolge
habe man mit vier raumsonden eine
leistung die 10.000.000 200 watt solar
modulen entspricht messen können project
von der west virginia university erklärt
für was diese messung gut ist bzw
noch gut sein kann zitat wenn
wissenschaftler mms nutzen können um zu
verstehen was auf kleinen skalen in der
magnetosphäre vorsicht geht können sie
dieses wissen auch auf andere bereiche
anwenden bei denen die re con acción
eine wichtige rolle spielt vom
weltraumwetter bis zur kernfusion
anwendung im labor zitat ende übrigens
kaum zu glauben aber solche ereignisse
im all können sich sogar auf das
irdische stromnetz auswirken also wenn
mal der strom ausfällt und keiner weiß
warum
vielleicht hat es ja gerade im all wie
knallt jetzt aber noch mal kurz zum
ironman anzug angenommen so ein anzug
wäre mal irgendwann im laden erhältlich
würdet ihr euch an solchen anzug kaufen
und welche funktionen sollte er haben
lasst es mich in den kommentaren wissen
schreibt mal eure wunschliste auf wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann freue
ich mich natürlich über einen daumen
nach oben
über ein kostenloses abo dass er da las
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran